welcome to another analog I'm your host
Lisa foils and today we're gonna be
doing one thing one thing only killing
next
so Wolfenstein franchise has completely
revived itself with the new order a
brand new FPS for 360 ps3 Xbox one ps4
and PC the game has a simplicity that
feels familiar and an emotional story we
never saw coming
so if you want more look no further here
are games similar to Wolfenstein the new
order
now what is the new order well let's
just say that history has been rewritten
so that the Nazis won World War two
yikes fast forward to the 60s and our
hero BJ blaskowitz wakes up to this
terror and his story of survival and
resistance begins now if you like the
new order because of the surprisingly
in-depth story you might want to give
Metro last light a try following Metro
2033 a post-apocalyptic Russia suffers
from such hostile environments muties
and unbreathable air that you're forced
to live underground the story is similar
in the sense that the protagonist is
struggling with what's happened in the
past horrified by events that have
occurred which led to this now
out-of-control world
Wolfenstein sometimes suffers from an
identity crisis going from cheeseball to
oh yeah we should probably be respectful
about the war Metro does not have this
problem it knows exactly what it is
Metro nails its dystopian tone perfectly
with ravage tunnel settings that feel
much like the dingy industrial locations
of new order it keeps things very dark
while recognizing just the right time to
add in a lighthearted piece of dialogue
let's drink to the fact we are still
alive you'll also appreciate the added
fantasy elements such as mutants and
mutated wildlife which might remind you
the robot dogs from new order
the biggest difference between the two
games is you'll rarely gun down a
hundred enemies it's more about
scurrying around in quiet fear that
you're gonna die at any moment
so have fun with that and just as a side
note Metro 2033 and last light are being
released as a pack for the new consoles
this summer so keep an eye out one of
the coolest perks about the new order is
well the perks the game is very
conducive to your play style similar to
Dishonored Wolfenstein allows you to
upgrade certain abilities without
needing skill points you simply play the
way you want to and that ability will
become stronger and easier Dishonored
shares this pliability dishonored lets
you be creative how do you want to kill
this guy do you want to shoot him spear
him knife in and speaking of knife in
Wolfenstein has been praised for its
stealth features and similarly
Dishonored thrives on allowing you to
sneak around and take out enemies before
they even know you're there dishonored
his first-person and set in a past time
period yes but in this game you have
superpowers
you'll lightning zap someone with your
left hand while slitting a throat with
your right again it's conducive to your
style of play
the best power is called blink which
lets you warp forward a short distance
and say to an enemy surprise I just came
out of nowhere and shank you only we
have that against the Nazis
Wolfenstein sets itself apart from other
current shooters by stripping back a lot
of the modern FPS cliches and playing
like an old-school shooter it ends up
feeling a lot like half-life 2 how many
shooters these days make you pick up
health packs instead of hiding behind a
boulder until you mysteriously recover
it's a throwback to the way shooters
used to play Plus both Wolfenstein and
half-life 2 encourage you to walk around
and chat with NPCs one minute it's
explosive fights the next it's low-key
exploration you learn about your world
by eavesdropping and paying attention to
details there's also a similar sense of
atmosphere VJ blaskowitz awakens to find
the world enslaved by Nazis gordon
freeman awakens from stasis to find the
world enslaved by aliens both are bad
doesn't those are bad things you're part
of the resistance you depend on fellow
survivors things are really bleak and
you're not sure if the good guys gonna
pull it off in the end if you loved
Wolfenstein the lazer Kraftwerk gun
things get ready for half-life 2's
gravity gun wielding this thing is the
reason we love first-person shooters we
don't care if it's realistic we don't
care if it's outrageous we care that
it's fun as hell and this gun is fun as
hell yes you've heard everyone rave
about half-life 2 including molyneux
skid so it's time to crowbar it up and
gave it a try
tweet me at least the foils and let me
know which games remind you of
Wolfenstein the new order and then come
back and see me next time for another
episode of analog